all right is russ still cooking he gets
to go back into the kitchen on thursday
night against the arizona cardinals look
at the first five games
look at the last four specifically
the turnovers from 19 total touchdowns
and three turnovers to 10
and 10
chris
10 and 10. it prompted pete carroll
coach of the seahawks to address
yesterday the offensive balance or lack
thereof in seattle
you know get it all working we we need
to continue to run the football we need
that as part of our offense
not as much as we need to do more than
we did yesterday and uh we want to
continue to always work for the balance
i know all of the uh the publicity has
gone towards the throwing game and russ
has had a huge number starting this
thing off and we're still the probably
the close to the highest scoring team in
the nfl and we expect to get back to
that and we need all of our offense to
get that done
look you can't be one-dimensional
regardless of whether to what extent
you're showcasing a great quarterback
and setting him up to be the one who
gets the bulk of the numbers
you can't be one-dimensional whether
you're running it all the time or
passing it all the time because at some
point
you will encounter someone that's right
who will take away that one dimension
you're focusing on yes and you're not
going to be able to do the other thing
right every team's got kryptonite and
the rams got a front four that can
corral russell wilson
and they have their version of dk
metcalf on defense and jaylen ramsey to
go okay now what's your next move and
there's just not a next move that's
where they need the run game that's
where they really miss chris carson and
his physicality running up between the
line of scrimmage you know this is a
great explosive drop back pass offense
but it's not one to where hey they they
rely on they got all the plays you need
it's not one of those offenses where i
go oh my gosh this amazing play design
it's amazing they got all the plays you
need and then they rely on their players
to make the plays with and off of that
and that usually works and it's going to
work against a lot of football teams but
as we saw in a game like sunday you know
they're running the ball important and
then hey you can't just go we're going
to line up dk over here and if he gets a
man we're going to throw it to him yeah
that's going to work against most teams
in football but this is one it's not and
what are you going to do to help him out
and do something you know deandre
hopkins they throw some receiver screens
some pick plays do things like that they
gotta have some answers for that to get
him involved in case that happens again
too because he's too good not to let him
touch the ball more than he did on
sunday
and it may be quite as simple as the
seahawks came out with his new look
offense
motivated by an effort to placate
russell wilson who wants to show more
frequently that he's as good as the best
quarterbacks in the game and after four
or five games of it
teams are able to scheme against it sure
teams are able to take away what they're
trying to do and the running game has
been ignored so yeah you know i i think
this gives pete carroll ammunition to go
back to russ and say i know you want to
rack up these big numbers and we're
going to try to do that but
we have to have balance yeah i think we
have to create balance yeah i think
he'll be able to sell that though and go
your numbers are going to be better if
we have just a little bit more balance
it's going to create some of those big
plays we saw early in the year that you
know we haven't seen as much of lately
uh to where yeah and you know right now
hey listen this graphic we're showing
right here says it all it's just it's
it's a lot of pressure on him he's doing
it all right leading the team in russian
leaning the team and throwing bringing
them back the defense stinks you know
that's just uh you're gonna have moments
like that like you said when you play
that team that just seems to match up
the right way against you
leave that up there i i
i don't know how many guesses i would
have needed to get daniel jones as
number three yeah right i would have
guessed lamar jackson russell wilson
kyler murray and kylo murray is just
eight yards behind kenyon drake as the
leading rusher in arizona murray's on
pace to have over a thousand yards he's
got 604 but i would i would have i i
don't know when i would have gotten
around to daniel jones maybe at some
point it would have flashed in my mind
he had that long run where he did the
face plant so that probably has boosted
him and they don't have saquon barkley
but it would have taken a while for me
to finally spin back around to daniel
johnson yeah no i only knew it just
because i've seen the stat a little bit
you know lately but he he may every game
has
one or two runs where you go he ripped
off 15. he ripped off 20. well that was
a nice run you know straight away he can
move a little bit certainly wayne
gallman though coming on for them but uh
i just i think that to back to seattle
you know i i do i think pete carroll
they got to get back to just a little
balance too you know two just to help
their defense out that's another issue
again they can't be like you know
sitting there with the way they play
where oh man rustling company it's three
passes in a row they're off the field
we're back on there
uh that's not going to be the proper
formula for them to succeed on that side
of the ball either
another thing that you've been
advocating and you know when you watch
other games you see it happen in the
cardinals bills game a quick pass to
larry fitzgerald just to get him
involved right
then there's no way they can stop it he
takes a step back from the line kyle
murray has the ball and shotgun you
throw it to larry fitzgerald you got a
couple receivers blocking you give him a
chance to gain seven or eight yards just
to get the feel of the football in his
hand that's right
that's right yeah and and here's dk
metcalf
with jalen ramsey covering him 37 snaps
with ramsay on him two targets no
catches when are and
is it really that hard are they caught
in this never-ending blender of activity
and they don't listen to anyone because
if you listen to anyone how do you avoid
listening to everyone but how is it not
dawned on the seahawks
that they should find ways to get the
ball into the hands of dk metcalf other
than him running a pass route and
getting open yeah that's that's what it
is it's all about just like him doing it
you know and yeah they call plays to be
aggressive and russell wilson's a great
deep ball thrower
but
you're you know you're you're right and
you're you know what you're saying there
you know the way they use him is hey
line up over here
if you got 101 we expect you to beat
them you know if you don't and it's
double coverage we we got other ways
we're going to use offense over here so
they kind of use him as that pawn all
the time
you know but yeah there's going to be
games and teams like we see where
they're going to have the proper game
plan to where
yes
you know what you're saying where you
know kansas city tyree kill there's
always screens early in the game there's
a speed sweep there's something just to
get him going get the ball in his hands
that to me is where they dropped the
ball a little bit i'd like to see dk on
the debo samuel toss plays anything like
that i think that will all go that way
and if he's going to be playing
man-to-man like that
you know i know he's a freak but the guy
covered him is a freak too every now and
then i mean we can pick and rub and do
those type of things never saw that
throughout the game either i'm excited
to watch the film back of that game
today and really see how that matchup
unfolded
i mean think about the ways they use
tyreek hill even as a decoy everywhere
loop him loop him into the backfield
right and so you've all of a sudden
you've got 11 guys on defense and uh oh
and even if you never even move in his
direction you've frozen them you've made
them think that the best athlete on the
field is going to get the football so
why aren't we seeing that d you know the
dk that that little jet sweep touch pass
that counts as a forward pass right you
get dk metcalf with a head of steam
going across the formation
shotgun formation snap to russell wilson
flip it to dk metcalf and just let him
go yeah just see what he can do right
because i have a feeling he can do some
great things eventually no doubt about
it i mean i think that's where you know
yes that's the next phase of that
offense they got to go there to get
touches if
if if i can figure it out it can't be
that hard i mean you at least played and
you've worked with teams and you know
you you've been inside of it and maybe
part of it is me learning from being
around you but it can't be that hard
why is it that hard no i know well you
know as an offensive coordinator hey
they've had success and you know i've
you know okay i never did these type of
things in my offense and then you start
this year and you go hey everything's
working
but i think it goes back to it's like 10
weeks of film teams start to find little
better ways to corral wilson take away
some of the past concepts that have been
effective and you need to continue to
grow and have more bells and whistles
and things like that and i i do i think
that's something you know hey robert
woods speed sweeps the things you talked
about all of those the wide receiver
screens didn't we the feeling
like even the feeling screen pass for
the touchdown last night was that am i
thinking of the right game but yeah
there's ways to get him more touches and
get him involved they need to do that
it's only going to help out the rest of
their football team
here's the message to anyone out there
who is an offensive coach at any level
whether you are a coordinator trying to
become a head coach or just not get
fired whether you're quality control and
working your way up the best offensive
coaches create the time and the capacity
every week to not just focus on their
playbook they focus on what other teams
are doing they focus on what has worked
league wide is there some new trend that
i can steal there's no shame in it steal
it if you see something that someone
else is doing that is working you're not
going to get any trouble right not going
to get sued right no one's going to say
you stole that
from the 1983 miami dolphins no
anything you can use anything you can
see
watch highlights watch every touchdown
from the week that was
understand what beats that d just don't
don't get so caught up in your system
you the defense you're about to face has
serious flaws somewhere they only have
11 guys it's amazing to me because i
know what the best offensive coaches do
they're doing they find time yeah to not
just say
what do we have to do
with our attack no
what are the other teams doing that's
working against this defense we're
facing what's working lead wide what is
what can we bring to the table
that they're not going to expect
that maybe makes better use of our
players it really isn't that difficult
folks and maybe maybe you know what
chris i look and and
i i know everybody's got to make their
own personal choice about how much time
they devote
to their professional
exploits i'm at a point in my life where
i got nothing else to do i work from the
moment i get up to the moment i go to
bed right i mean a little leisure time
but not much
um
if you want to rise to the top of the
coaching profession you got to find time
you got to make time to take it next
level and i feel like too many guys
can't or won't put in the time necessary
to take it next level either they either
they don't know what to do
or they're not willing to put in the
time to do it yeah or a combination of
both that's the difference between the
great and the good and those who get
fired uh yes i mean 100 i mean whether
it is you have the extra hours in the
office to do things like that or
you know the wait in real hours not
hanging around drinking coffee i know
it's shot in the grinder breeze almost
said a different word real work grind
and grind work hard play hard win hard
and uh you know and then have a boat
where every year you got to change the
name of it because you won another super
well that's the that's it there you go
about checking everybody out well yeah i
mean you're right i mean they're they
grind to death and we've always talked
about that it's one of their great
advantages they outcompete the other
coaching staff almost on a weekly basis
but like mcdaniels sean payton
kyle shanahan
you know
i guarantee
that they have john gruden i know so i
don't have to guarantee that one i know
all right they
at some point to what you're saying
during the week are going to sit down
and watch two or three of the offensive
coordinators they really respect in
football and just see what they did for
the week let me run through their game
real quick and see their plays let me
just see oh whoa whoa oh oh that was
cool okay i like that would they do that
all right all right i'm gonna do that
and they might not do it that week but
all of a sudden it gets infused into the
practice schedule to where now you
practice it two or three weeks and then
all of a sudden oh here's the game to
break it out there's that play i took
from sean payton three weeks ago now
we're gonna break it out and here we go
that's what the really good ones do
you're right mike all the way and you
know maybe this will be the the nudge
that gives schottenheimer that all right
i gotta our our formula that's been
working to this point's not now i need
to expand and go to the next level and
maybe he does that this week
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports